hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and on the podcast we've talked in
various different ways about complexity
about complex systems
and there are few systems more complex
than
all of humanity all of humankind i'm not
even sure how best to quantify
uh the total amount of complexity in a
system like is humanity as a system
more complex than an individual human
brain
it's not clear to me i know that there's
lots of different brains in humanity but
a level complexity need not be
higher but anyway we agree that humanity
as a whole is a complex system so you
can think about it
using the tools of complexity theory
using the concepts like
networks and interconnections and tiny
pieces
interacting non-linearly but giving rise
to emergent collective phenomena
so today's guest is neil ferguson neil
is a very well-known
historian both academically and in the
public sphere
he thinks about big questions of global
history
western culture especially but also the
world more broadly
and what i didn't know before inviting
him on the podcast is he comes from a
family of physicists
and he tends to think about history in
terms of
networks and complexity theory so a
recent book by neil is called the square
in the tower where he literally
thinks about different parts of history
that have been dominated by
more or less equal kinds of networks
between people
versus hierarchical networks and a
follow-up book is called doom this is a
very recent book that he wrote during
the current and still ongoing global
pandemic about covet 19
all the ways in which a complex
political system can try to deal with
a crisis a catastrophe okay something
like the global pandemic is an example
but there are many other examples from
earthquakes to wars to famines and so
forth
and it matters how you organize your
society and in many
ways as we've seen there are ways in
which current modern societies
did okay fighting the global pandemic
certainly on the science side
the discovery of vaccines was a
wonderful
accomplishment of humankind and some
complex system was needed for that but
on the political side
we did less well we're not as good in uh
the political systems we have in dealing
with
big large-scale catastrophes the kind
that only come along
very rarely in in human history so how
do you deal with that or the lessons
that we can learn from this
uh those of you who know the work of
neil ferguson will know that he and i
are
not close to each other on the political
spectrum but even though there's a lot
of politics involved
in this conversation there's no partisan
politics involved we're both trying to
understand
the system that works and we all want it
to work in the same way in the sense of
saving people's lives dealing well
with these kinds of issues so i think
it's a very fruitful conversation one
that really has a lot of important
insights
that we can put to work both thinking
about the world as a system and thinking
about how
practically speaking to deal with the
future catastrophes that are inevitably
to come
so with that let's go
[Music]
neil ferguson welcome to the mindscape
podcast it's a pleasure to be an
honor to be with you sean i always like
it when the
when the guest begins with that i gotta
we need to have a contest for the guests
to be more and more effusive when they
come on so i'm glad that you're
playing along and i i also i want to
start by letting the audience know
that you uh as we were emailing without
me prompting you mentioned that you come
from a family of physicists i think that
your
mother is a physics teacher i just want
them to know because i'm always having
these guests on who do something very
different but then they reveal that
they were either an undergraduate
physics major or they come from
physicists or they're married to a
physicist i don't seek you people out
you just sort of naturally appear on the
podcast does that does that
color how you think about history which
is generally what you do
undoubtedly i'm the black sheep of the
family my
my mother uh studied physics at glasgow
university
and she was a physics teacher science
teacher
and my father was a physician and
my sister is a physicist at yale
who is publishes papers
the titles of which i don't understand
quite apart from the content she works
in the
physics of cell membranes uh with her
husband
mark lemon and so i'm the black sheep
because i
i ended up becoming a historian i think
part of my reason for doing that
was a kind of fascination with
particles that consciousness and
essentially historians are studying
these strange
uh particles called humans and reading
tolstoy
as a schoolboy persuaded me that that
was
the path i wanted to go down to give my
parents
credit they never discouraged me from
doing this
but there's no question that the fact of
of coming from a scientific family
had a big influence on my my approach to
history
and and i think set me apart from most
historians from fairly early on
for example i was drawn towards economic
history at oxford because
there was this potential for
quantification that seemed to be lacking
in other
fields and and i'd i'd been given a
jolly good mathematical training at
glasgow academy
i was better at math than my english
contemporaries so it was
comparative advantage to do that kind of
work but i
i owe my parents a huge debt because
i grew up in a household where
scientific questions were discussed over
dinner
and the books on the shelves included
books
popular histories and popular science
books
and there was never a kind of two
cultures divide in our family
it was uh you went from discussing
questions of
evolutionary biology to talking about
shakespeare without the sense that one
was somehow crossing a barrier
well it shows up uh in your book the
square in the tower which is one of the
books i want to talk about
one of our previous guests here on
mindscape was steven strogatz who did
the early work on small world networks
and there there was his name
right on page 30 or something like that
uh in your book
so if i can summarize it in a phrase you
should uh correct me on this but
you're looking in that book at history
through the lens of
networks network theory in particular
networks versus hierarchies is that
more or less right that's right
historians
often talk about networks but they don't
really
think terribly rigorously about what
they mean
we all use the word rather casually in
everyday life i'm going to network at
this party etc and i
i'd realized over a period of time that
i
actually could be much more precise in
the way that i talked about networks
that i'd been writing about networks
from early on in my career networks of
bankers
in 1920s germany networks of
uh colonizers in a book about the
british empire but i hadn't really
understood much about
network structure network science
network theory
and so i write about the time that i
moved from harvard to stanford i went on
a kind of reading binge to educate
myself
realizing that that network theory had
evolved
in multiple disciplines uh mathematics
of course
was where it had really begun but there
were people working on networks in
sociology there were people working on
networks in economics
there were people working on networks in
medical science
and i and i got to know one of the
preeminent physicists working
on networks lashla barabasi and between
conversations with him uh
readings of people like
stephen strogatz uh getting to know
nicholas christakis i
i was a kind of otter didac network
scientist
the point was to try and apply the
insights from these different
areas to history and i didn't think that
had been done
before really hadn't so the idea was to
write a book
in which human history was explained
in terms of social networks primarily
but of course
there are all kinds of other networks
that are relevant
and i found that a way to simplify the
story for the lay reader because clearly
most people who pick up a book like the
square in the tower
haven't come across strogatz's work uh
might be coming across it for the first
time the idea was
that there are hierarchies that are
pretty well established and familiar
social structures
governments states armies are very
hierarchically configured
and they're important in history and
historians tend to gravitate towards
them because hierarchical
structures leave archives they're much
more likely to leave written records
but equally important are network
social networks but they don't leave
such
good written records and therefore their
role is less obvious and
much less represented in the written
record now you know because you're a
physicist that that's a false dichotomy
that we're actually talking about two
different kinds of network a
hierarchically structured network
and a distributed or decentralized
network and the book kind of gets you
there
but it starts with the intuitive
distinction between
hierarchies and networks and goes from
there
i loved writing that book i found it
extraordinarily illuminating to rethink
for example the reformation as an
assault in a hierarchical structure the
roman catholic church by a network of
uh of reforming uh ministers led by
uh by luther but not really led by him
uh
perhaps uh uh he was the catalyst but
the network
was not really one that he led so i
i think this is a really powerful tool
for historians
that needs to be more widely adopted
there
are now historians who work on
a whole range of subplots from the the
elizabethan
reformation all the way through to the
the cambridge spies
who use network science more rigorously
and i learned a lot from those people
who had done that kind of work
so this was a work of synthesis supposed
to kind of show that there was a general
approach that one could take and it was
applicable
pretty much to any historical problem
yeah i mean i'm
all too sympathetic to uh this
perspective you're absolutely speaking
my language and therefore
let me try to play the devil's advocate
role a little bit here
um there is an attitude that says well
sure people form networks and
hierarchies also count as networks and
everything is a network so
so what so what do we learn by throwing
the word network in there is there
is there a particular kind of insight or
is there a particular kind of
quantitative way of thinking about it i
mean how given that there was a network
of people talking to each other
in the reformation how do we figure out
what the
degree of connectivity of a typical node
was that sounds very hard
it's not quite so hard as as you might
think you you can
graph networks uh if you have enough
information about the relationships
between the people
in them that the edges between the nodes
even for the 16th century this is
possible and
there's some terrific work that i cite
showing that one reason the reformation
succeeded was that the network was
sufficiently
distributed that you couldn't actually
kill it by
uh making martyrs of the apparent
leaders
because the the the network would
survive the removal of
key nodes uh with the american
revolution we we can
actually work out which leaders or
well-known figures in the american
revolution
were in network terms the most important
in terms of centrality
say betweenness centrality paul revere
turned out to be
really important from that point of view
so it's not just a kind of
metaphor which some reviewers thought
it's actually
a way of of attaching uh weight
to individual nodes yeah so i mean i
guess the point could be said
as sure networks are everywhere and
throwing around the word network doesn't
help us very much but there are
different
kinds of networks and there are kinds of
things you can say about networks that
apply equally well whether they're
viral or technological or social and
maybe that does actually shed some
insight
i think it does part of it is of course
to
push against the great man theory of
history
that we have for many centuries
tended to write history with the
emphasis on kings and queens and
presidents
and the the network approach allows you
to show that
often network structure social network
structure is different from the org
chart
uh sure george washington's sort of at
the top of the orc part of the american
revolution but
in terms of actually building a
revolution
paul revere may have been as important
revolutions after all are not
by and large organized by existing
hierarchical entities
so what's interesting about the
networked approach to revolution is that
you begin to understand why some
revolutions succeed and others fail
that's part of it i think it's also
about understanding the changing
structure of the public sphere
broadly defined or indeed the changing
structure of
the global economy jurgen habermas's
structural change in the public sphere
was a tremendously influential work
i began to realize that it was a kind of
intimation of this approach what's
interesting about the enlightenment for
example which has been
such a huge part of our lives it's the
birth of the modern
in many ways uh intellectually
is that it's the product of a
distinctive and quite cosmopolitan
network
of thinkers who communicate partly by
publishing and partly by writing letters
and so you can graph that and understand
that the enlightenment which we all have
a hazy notion of as in fact
quite clearly defined network of
individuals
with a finite number of of nodes and
edges
i find that tremendously helpful much
intellectual history is disembodied
ideas kind of
spread through some magical process they
become dominant through some
paradigm shift but but the network
science approach
allows you to track this and give
definition to
intellectual change as well as political
revolutions
we live in this world of unprecedented
uh connectedness the pandemic has
illustrated
the vulnerabilities of such a world but
i was
inclined to argue in the square in the
tower that there were other ways in
which a hyper-connected world could be
unstable
and the analogy that i wanted to draw
was between
the printing press and the experience of
16th and 17th century europe and the
internet and our contemporary world
because it seems to me that
the technological change made possible
by the internet and the personal
computer
has had similar impacts but on a global
level
to the impacts of the printing press
ultimately hierarchical institutions
don't want information to be
that free and they don't want so many
people to be able to generate and share
content
so i think it's a profoundly helpful
analogy
a lot of people want to think about the
21st century with 20th century analogies
it's the it's the default setting for
journalists oh
x is it's the 1930s all over again
whatever it is
and part of the point of the square in
the tower was to say no because actually
the mid-20th century was a time when
communications technology allowed highly
centralized control that's why
totalitarianism
was possible we live in a time of
decentralized
distributed communication though that
has somewhat been offset by the rise of
network platforms but it's still more i
think like the 16th and 17th century
than it is like the mid-20th century
so that was part of the the argument of
the book well definitely the
connection between uh distributed
networks
and revolutions was very it was a very
interesting one i mean maybe we could
uh bring it down to earth a little bit
if you want to say more about paul
revere i mean it's a provocative claim
to say that paul revere
played just as big a role in the
american revolution as george washington
did
well there's a lovely paper and i'm
blanking on the author's name because
it's now been three years i think since
i wrote the book
up which shows up and graphs quite
carefully the
the network the social network of the
american revolution in in and around
boston
the revolution like many revolutions had
its origins in association life
people don't hatch plots to
establish independent republics just
over the dinner table with their wives
and kids
this was something that took shape in a
variety of different associations of
which
the masonic lodges turned out to have
been the most important and the argument
of the paper is that
if you look at all the key participants
in the revolutionary movement
in boston only a couple
were members of just about every one of
these associations
and and one of the two was paul revere
revere is famous for his
nocturnal ride i think it may still be
the case that school children
are taught about that or perhaps it's
been cancelled i i don't recall where
paul rivera stands in the wokeness
stakes but at any event people used to
know about paul revere's ride
the point about paul revere's ride which
malcolm gladwell made
years ago is that revere was a well
enough known person
for his warnings to be credible if a
perfect stranger had been riding you
know to concord or
lexington saying that the redcoats are
coming it might not have been nearly as
uh as forceful a warning what gladwell
missed was
the the crucial role of the masonic
orders now that's interesting because
freemasons have long occupied this
somewhat shadowy part
in the history of the 18th century we
know masonic lodges were very important
we knew
we know that they spread all over europe
and north america
but the people who used to write about
them were often
if not conspiracy theorists certainly
writing a kind of history that
that leaned in the direction of the
conspiracy theory
what i was able to show was that there
really was a significant
over-representation of masons in the
leadership of the american revolution
and that was important not only
organizationally but also in terms of
its of the ethos of the revolution uh
washington as a mason was also
seems at least plausibly a
deist uh who was
depicted in his masonic regalia more
than once
so that's the kind of thing that i think
historians have generally downplayed
downplayed because it's not a kind of
official version of events
and i think you can write about that
without drifting into the realm of
of of conspiracy theory i'd had a
similar encounter
years ago 20 years ago writing the
history of the rothschild family
who feature in any number of conspiracy
theories but
when you look carefully into their
archives there was a tremendously
powerful network
of mostly jewish financial families and
institutions
that was crucial to the evolution of
19th century
uh financial uh capitalism
and so i'm i'm excited by the
possibility that one can bring these
networks
into the mainstream of historiography
rather than leaving them with
the internet conspiracy theorists
mindscape listeners know how much a fan
i am of the great courses plus
a streaming service that gives you
access to thousands of courses
at a high level on all sorts of topics
from playing music to learning a
language to reading about history
and now i have an incredible deal for
the listeners here you can get a free
trial
with 20 off when you sign up for the
annual membership
but you have to go to the special url
the great
courses plus dot com slash mindscape
that's a world of knowledge for less
than what most of us pay for coffee
each month i've made courses myself for
the great courses one of my favorites
was the higgs boson
and beyond which talks not only about
the higgs boson but also about the large
hadron collider
quantum field theory and how particle
physics works it's still very topical in
a day when we might be getting new hints
of new physics from particle physics
experiments
so don't miss out on this great deal go
now to
dot com thegreatcoursesplus.com
mindscape to get your free trial and get
twenty percent off the annual membership
that's
the great courses plus dot com slash
mindscape it does sound like these
post printing press networks that you're
saying played such a big role
are a little bit in between uh the
completely hierarchical top-down
washington was the general he told us
what to do view
versus maybe a more contemporary view
where literally everyone is on
twitter jabbering with each other so
it's a social network but it's a social
network that is also still pretty elite
in some sense right the right people
talk to the right other people
well barabasi taught me that the social
networks
uh that we encounter are typically
scale free or close to scale free
by which i mean uh that there is a sort
of power law distribution
that operates and a very small number of
nodes have
an enormous number of edges and a lot of
edges of hardly any
nodes so there's not a kind of bell
curve shape to the
distribution of of nodes and i think of
edges rather and i think
this idea the the um
the matthew effect that when people join
a social network they're more likely to
want to be connected to
say donald trump or before he got
cancelled that is
than to little old me i think
that's a really important point that
when you come down to looking at
at social networks in the wild as it
were
in historical reality they're never
lattices in which everybody has roughly
the same number of edges they're always
quite like uh barabasi's skill-free
networks if not exactly
scale-free so i think that's that's a
key point
we think of the internet as this
decentralized
place at least we used to maybe we've
got over it now but we used to think we
were all kind of netizens
uh and we could all speak truth to power
and all that stuff
but in truth the network structure
changed with tremendous speed
as the network platforms i guess
beginning with amazon
uh concentrated more and more traffic
onto their
uh onto their sites so the internet's
actually a good illustration of the
point that
left to themselves networks don't in
fact stay
i use the word flat advisedly here they
don't they don't
stay truly distributed and they quite
quickly
form these on these extraordinary uh
lopsided architectures where
you know the the fit get fitter or the
rich get richer whatever the appropriate
term is
yeah i mean everyone can be on twitter
but not everyone has the same number of
followers that's
clearly true certainly not the same
influence um
so let me let me do my last little bit
of pushing back here against this idea
because the
main distinction you draw in the book is
between networks by which as you said
you mean more distributed networks
versus hierarchies and you make a point
the hierarchies keep records so later
historians tend to pay attention to them
but i could imagine an almost similar
distinction that is not quite the same
between institutions and more casual
collections right
is the important thing about the state
or the corporation or the university or
whatever that it's a hierarchy
or is the important thing that it's an
institution with some memory
some records some physical location in
space
certainly the things that historians
tend to write about
are the things that for reasons of their
own have left written records
and uh that that tends to mean
uh states governments uh
to some extent in the modern period
corporations though they don't keep
records nearly as well as
as governments it hasn't met meant
secret societies by definition the
illuminati did not really want to have a
single
depository of of material where the
bavarian authorities could
uh could find all that they had done
that was illegal
uh same goes for the mafia very hard to
write the history of organized crime
they don't really have a mafia archive
and so i think you're right the
distinction is partly
how far a network became
institutionalized enough to have
an archive and a well-managed archive
that was likely to survive
over time i put it somewhat differently
i think we need to somehow look past the
facade of institutions
uh and see that however hierarchical
they may be
however pyramidal the org chart
all organizations of human beings
no matter how formal or informal have a
network architecture that we ought to be
able to
draw and that network architecture will
look very different from the org chart
regardless really of the context so
yeah institutions are are really what
leave
records behind secret societies not so
much
but you can still understand an
institution using network science
and i think that's a very important
point that not many
institutions today fully understand i'm
always struck by how few firms
and how few uh academic institutions
know their own network i mean they have
an org chart
but they believe in that org chart
and often blindly without recognizing
that
in fact the the true social architecture
of the institution is
quite different from what the org chart
says
so yeah i think that's that's how i come
to think of it i'll give you one other
example which goes right back to my
early work
on the first world war in a book called
the pity of war i was trying to
understand why
despite its significant material
disadvantages the german army
outperformed in battle
the other armies in particular the
british army
and one of the things i learned from the
military historians was that
although one thinks of prussian
militarism as quintessentially
hierarchical
in reality that was the british army it
was in the british
army that you sat in the foxhole waiting
for orders
even what was unlikely that orders could
reach you the german army in fact had a
culture of delegated authority to ncos
that encouraged small groups to take the
initiative in the battlefield
so although i didn't know anything about
it at the time i could have written
that in terms of network structure the
german army was far more of a
distributed network
and therefore in fact far more versatile
and responsive to changing
battlefield conditions it was the
british army that was
actually held back by the waiting for
orders mentality
the philosopher of science in me wants
to draw a connection which i'm sure that
you've already made yourself
to theories of evolution and natural
selection
where the unit of evolutionary selection
is hotly debated right both among
biologists and philosophers is it
the gene is it the organism is it a
group or a family or something like that
so
uh and complexity theorists santa fe
type folks have
thought about this a lot i mean and is
that the difference between the british
and the prussian armies like
what counts as a group of people making
decisions
yeah that's a good analogy that i hadn't
thought of in in
writing the square in the tar as well as
in
the most recent book doom i have been
quite influenced by
santa fe writers thinkers
i've certainly tried to theorize a lot
as an historian about
complexity in political structures as
well as
military structures and i've been
influenced by jeffrey west's work for
example
uh which is in scale a brilliant attempt
to
to think about uh everything it's a kind
of
the key to all mythologies if one were
to try to apply
and it's dangerous to do this um
evolutionary
uh frameworks to human history
first of all somebody would say stop
it's no longer allowed do not go there
on
pain of of cancellation but then you'd
kind of step back and say
well what is is the right way to think
about
about war a hundred years ago
when social darwinism was a dominant way
of thinking
it was seen as some kind of
quasi-darwinian process
and i don't think anybody thinks about
it that way that way now
i think we probably get further
asking the question which i think
applies beyond the realm of war
what form of of organization
is best uh suited to
a dangerous environment of
uncertainty and potentially
non-linear change and i i think that's
the right way to
to put this not so much in in biological
terms but in terms of
organizational behavior and there's no
question that having
a a relatively dis decentralized
architecture and information flows that
go up as well as down
an organization will adapt better to the
unexpected shock
i'm not sure if this is a question or a
statement that maybe you can comment on
but
what you just said makes me think of the
following thing which i've
puzzled about a little bit um evolution
famously what it does is it doesn't look
ahead right it just tries all sorts of
different things and some things work
and persist and some things don't but
it's not teleological it's not aiming in
some direction
whereas when we human beings design
something in principle we can think of
all the various things that can happen
and try to protect against them right uh
but you know you just mentioned sort of
the robustness
uh or the the ability to survive
disasters of these different
systems and yet i think that evolution
is much better than human beings at
designing systems that are robust when i
break a leg it will heal when my car
gets a flat
something has to intervene from the
external world you know that
somehow evolution has this power to plan
ahead even though it doesn't try
that's right we we as human beings
want to optimize and we rule out
multiple experiments
that evolution would run uh ex-ante
so we really narrow the range of of of
possible
mutations and this is a point nasim
talibs made
very well in a number of books i guess
anti-fragile being the best we don't
really like redundancy in our systems
so we we optimize uh we reduce the
number of
experiments that might otherwise happen
and we
create fragility in the process and this
is i think a fundamental problem of
of human design whether we're designing
armies
or banks or universities that that we
don't in fact
uh think enough about resilience uh
much less anti-fragility uh in the face
of a shock
we keep kind of learning or not learning
rather from this
experience think of the fragility that
the financial crisis
exposed uh in the in the international
financial system and
at its core in banks i think that
problem had been been building for some
time because of the strong
impulse to to optimize uh
for efficiency and minimize costs so you
ran down the capital until you had a
massively overextended balance sheet in
relation to capital
i don't think we've learned early much
because it seems to me the public health
systems of the world were exposed in
just the same way in 2020
as very good at producing pandemic
preparedness plans
but not actually very good at coping
with a real pandemic
and i think that that made me think back
to how the banks would tell you in 2006
how tremendously well prepared they were
to manage risk
until an actual risk happened and they
all were on the verge of insolvency
well it's it's an excellent point i
think because you know these systems
that are built by human beings
are optimized for something uh
but somehow they're even more
short-sighted in what they're being
optimized for than the biological ones
are
and um i mean uh taleb's book
anti-fragile is sitting on my bookshelf
but i haven't read it yet so i'm not
going to pretend but
are there does this kind of analysis
suggest ways we can do better at
building more
resilient systems yes
i think i'll not attempt to
paraphrase uh nasim's book though it's
great fun and in some ways my favorite
of his
books but let me illustrate it with
some examples from doom
if you were a highly
bureaucratic public health system
that optimized for central control
and risk minimization
as i think cdc the centers for disease
control in the united states did your
response to the news of a novel pathogen
from wuhan was in fact to make
it harder to test for that pathogen
rather than making it much easier and
this was a
an epic fail that emanated from
i think an increasingly sclerotic
bureaucratic culture at cdc
that would have been unrecognizable to
the people who founded the institution
in the post-war period by contrast
in taiwan the response
to any threat from china regardless of
whether it's
uh authentically viral or it is
uh it is uh uh
information warfare is immediate
and rapid uh reaction
and the taiwanese ramped up testing
launched contact tracing and had a
digital system of quarantining
within weeks of the first news even
before the who had confirmed it was
human to human transmission i take from
that
that it is better to be generally
paranoid
which i think you have to be in taiwan
for obvious reasons
and in south korea than it is to be very
specifically prepared
the problem about western bureaucracies
is that they are excessively
precise in the risks that they
are preparing for this was also true in
financial regulation
financial regulation before 2008 had got
increasingly complicated the basel
rules on bank capital adequacy went from
a few pages to enormous numbers of pages
and paradoxically the more they prepared
for the specific eventuality of a stress
test on bank balance
sheets the less prepared they were i was
highly amused to find as i was
researching doom just how many pandemic
preparedness reports the american
bureaucracy had produced in the years
prior to twenty
endless pages of of reports about what
to do and powerpoint decks
but at the point of of of contact when a
real pandemic was happening the system
failed utterly that's the key for me
that we were super prepared in a way
that was illusory
i mean remember there was a ranking at
the end of 2019 that said the us and the
uk were the best prepared for a public
health emergency and it turned out to be
the very opposite
i don't think people have fully figured
out why because it's so
tempting to blame it all on donald trump
without our recognizing that there was a
systemic problem
that had its roots in the way the
bureaucratic mind
works the regulatory state
deals with all potential problems
in a way that appears to be
preparation but is in fact
some kind of almost magical
warding off of disaster through the
generation of powerpoint slides
we we have to recognize that is the
pathology because
it will be true whatever the disaster
that's my kind of general takeaway
so yeah i think there are ways to be
anti-fragile
and we need to go talk to the taiwanese
who've got a pretty anti-fragile system
at this point and the south koreans who
also got this very right
and we need to also have an inquest into
why our public health bureaucracies
across the western world
got this so badly wrong that was their
one job
yeah well i mean i'm extremely
sympathetic to this despite
the fact that uh you know politically
i'm definitely on the left side of
things i think the government can
solve problems and should help people
but boy there is a tendency within
bureaucracies
to imagine that we can
guess exactly what the problem is going
to be and only allow ourselves to solve
that and like you say that leaves us
really unable to be nimble when the
actual problems hit which are never the
problems that you
uh anticipated i remember i was teaching
at a summer school
in europe uh right when the eu
constitution was being debated and one
of the guest lectures was a very broad
summer school one of the guest lectures
was from stephen breyer the u.s supreme
court justice
and you could he was too polite to say
it out loud but he's like
this proposed eu constitution hundreds
of pages right
and he's like here's our constitution
that's worked pretty well it's a couple
pages long
because it doesn't try to pretend to
anticipate every single possible thing
and you
you have to allow for the system to
breathe a little bit but
i don't know how to actually do that in
practice i mean you can sort of exhort
people to try to do it but there is a
tendency there is a
there is some thing about the evolution
of these networks that
that falls into the ruts when it comes
to planning for the future
that's true it may be that we just can't
help ourselves
and that things that worked well 200
years ago
over time become sclerotic that was
really
manta olsen's point that you therefore
need periodic
uh disruption or destruction so the
institutions can be
refounded i
take a slightly more optimistic view
that it is possible
to repair as it were without
the plane crashing but i think it
requires a fundamental
reassessment of how we think about
risk remember that the way that the
regulatory or administrative state has
evolved
since the 1970s has been that when
congress saw something too
tricky it punted it to a new agency
starting with the
environmental protection agency and
within those agencies which now
uh number north of 60
responsible for all kinds of different
aspects of life
i think the same basic mentality
exists and this is a bureaucratic
mentality that we've
we've understood since the time of max
weber when when bureaucracy was still a
relatively novel phenomenon
what we have to figure out is how to
de-bureaucratize public services
and get away from the mentality of the
the 1970s and 80s regulatory state
that probably requires a reassessment of
the way in which we teach public
servants
because we definitely create a
legalistic mentality
that our law schools have a lot to
answer for
and that mentality that i think arises
there and i wrote about this in a book
called the great degeneration
is even if there is a point not one
percent probability that an asteroid
strikes the earth we need a regulatory
framework
uh that needs to be adopted uh it needs
to cover multiple pages before we're
really going to feel we've done our work
and
that's the disease and it exists not
only in the public sector but it exists
in the private sector as well every
large corporation
develops this pathology on every
university as i hardly need to tell you
hasn't too so what we need to devise i
think
uh is a kind of theory and practice of
de-bureaucratization
and a little bit of that mentality that
the german army used to have
in its uh in its 1914 incarnation where
there is significant delegation
to the the unit that has to
to act and that that's what we lack
we've seen this
so clearly with european vaccination
fiasco what went wrong there
power grabbed by the commission to try
to centralize control
of procurement and it went horrifically
but predictably wrong subsidiarity is a
word that europeans use
they just don't practice it there's a
bit of it in the u.s
at least we still have a federal system
that didn't work well when it came to
dealing with the initial outbreak but it
did work reasonably well when it came to
vaccination so i think we all need to
assess how our institutions work
whether we're in the private or public
sector and try to give
them something of the anti-fragility
feel
that there is empowerment of decision
making at lower levels
and there's much less explicit
regulation there needs to be
some kind of discretion and and we've
lost that because i think of the primacy
of
of law schools in in the education of
the administrative class
as difficult as it can be to get
exercising once again
it feels so good when it happens you can
catch and maintain that special burst of
motivation with peloton the exercise
bike that you can have in your home
they have inspiring instructors amazing
music endless fitness variety and
engaging community
what i like about peloton is the
convenience you can hop on the bike when
you feel like you're into it
and you can dial up exactly the kind of
workout you want to get
peloton isn't just cardio you can get a
strength class to your ride or combine
them both
in one workout with bike boot camp for
the total body fitness experience
one peloton subscription can cover the
whole family you can get an all-access
membership for no additional cost
and there are classes for every level
from beginner programs to tabata
intervals
peloton meets you at every step on your
fitness journey so get started on your
peloton journey by going to
one peloton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
i so i have no opinion about the
diagnosis of blaming the law schools but
you know it's very very plausible in my
mind
um good so we've slid very very
naturally from
the themes of your of the book that we
started with with the networks versus
hierarchies in the square in the tower
to
your new book doom which is a very good
title and the
the cover is the cover that i have seen
the actual cover that it's going to be
of the
guy the u.s ignition has a beautiful
photograph of a
gentleman playing golf with the wildfire
i think it's not far away from where i
live so
i'm very familiar i think it was taken
in oregon in 2017
okay it wasn't one of last year's
california wildfires but i remember
seeing the image at the time and
thinking
that capsule that encapsulates the
insouciant mentality
uh of americans today golfing while
the woods burn and presumably also while
the virus
spreads so yeah that is indeed the
jacket the uk has a different
has a different more historical jacket
but i i'm
i'm excited about this book because it
follows in a way from
from the square in the tower it's a it's
about what happens when a network
society is
is hit by contagion simultaneously by
a novel pathogen and by all kinds of
crazy conspiracy theories about
it and it's helped me think a little
further along
the the lines we began by discussing
history has a problem as a discipline
we are as a profession attracted to
disasters a lot of books are about
disasters whether natural or man-made
but we don't have a very good handle on
the
relationship between disasters and
our species so i wanted to write a
general theory of disaster
so that i could think simultaneously
about pandemics and wars
and financial crises and earthquakes and
volcanic eruptions
because they are so much um of what we
call history
and i came away with uh one very clear
view
namely that we couldn't possibly have a
cyclical theory of history of any sort
no matter how appealing cyclical
theories have been to people through
the ages because there are just too many
completely random randomly distributed
or
parallel distributed disasters for any
kind of rhythm to be
discernable and and we are as a species
um at the mercy of these extraordinarily
unpredictable
and uh uh very differently sized
and and differently differently formed
disasters that that's so much the story
of
of human history uh so that was exciting
to to do
because i'd been wanting to to think
about this for a while and the pandemic
gave me
the opportunity to do it systematically
well i think probably a lot of people in
their minds
would have as the options that history
is either cyclical
or it's progressive and the point is
it's neither one of those right it's a
lot noisier process than either one
yeah we've squeezed out some really
significant progress of course
particularly since the industrial
revolution or one might say since the
scientific revolution
and that's that's hugely important not
least because it's extended our life
spans
and reduce the probability that our
children die as children
but as i try to show the thing that
humanity
often has forgotten is that as we have
made material progress we've increased
our vulnerability
uh and the the networked world that
existed at the end of 2019 with
unprecedented volumes of passenger
traffic through the air
was of course a disaster waiting to
happen
and indeed it may it may be that others
uh of that form happen again because
after all by historical standards sars
sarsko v2
is not by any means uh the worst
pathogen we've ever encountered
uh in fact it's led us off very lightly
uh by historical standards so i think
these two arguments kind of come
together if you recognize that our
institutions
have a tendency to become sclerotic and
bureaucratic
and and that networks morph into rigid
hierarchies to put it really crudely
and that this goes on in a world which
is subject to pretty randomly
distributed disasters of various forms
you can see why we get into difficulties
because we
we don't really think about the world uh
in a realistic way
for example we will spend a lot of time
in the coming
weeks and months and years talking about
climate change
as if that is really the only disaster
we need to worry about
and that mentality was striking to me
over a year ago
at the beginning of 2020 at the world
economic forum
almost every panel seemed to be about
climate change and a pandemic had
obviously already begun
you couldn't get anybody to talk about
that but it was a much more clear and
present danger
so i worry that we are unwittingly
making the same mistake
of thinking a great deal about one
scenario
which is the sort of worst case climate
change scenario
it only needs volcanic eruptions to
revert to their medieval level
to having really big volcanic eruptions
for global cooling to be a
be our problem and when i started to
look at the geological record the first
thing that hit me was
wow we really stopped having big
volcanoes in 1815
like we haven't really had a big
eruption a real climate changing
eruption since then
i don't think there's any reason to
assume that that's just because the
earth got bored of big
big volcanoes sorry what do you what do
you assume
what do you imagine why did it happen
i don't think anybody has a clue okay
and i think it's
it's perfectly plausible given the ways
in which
over the very long run the scale of
volcanic eruptions has fluctuated that
at some point who knows when
we see another really big tambura-like
eruption
and that would be that would completely
blindside us because we just haven't
considered that as as a risk but it
seems to me a perfectly
real risk especially as we you know we
we really are now
in terms of the scale of population and
its distribution we have more people
sitting
next to more fault lines of volcanoes
than ever right
so i i think that the need and maybe
this is the key point that the book
makes
is to realize that disaster can come at
you in multiple forms
uh there is no clear distinction between
a man-made and natural disaster
in truth because ultimately it's it's
what we've done
before and what we do after that
determines how disastrous
an event like a volcano or or an
earthquake or a pandemic
is hence the subtitle the politics of
catastrophe
all catastrophes are ultimately
politically
mediated it's our decisions that
determine
the scale of the disaster if we've
decided to build
massive cities beside fault lines we
shouldn't be
too surprised when earthquakes cause
very large casualties and and i think
that
that means that we need to be more i
think broadly
aware of our vulnerabilities and less
preoccupied with just the ones that
happen to take our fancy
you know visions of the apocalypse have
been a feature of human life since the
earliest recorded times
we are drawn to the idea of
ultimate doom and i sense a lot of that
kind of
millennialism in some of what goes on in
the conversation about climate change
and it's very well worth worrying about
but it's definitely not the only way
that history can
can get us there are lots of different
ways it can get us and it can get us a
lot more quickly
by some of these other ways i mean
climate change is a slow moving thing
a pathogen is a very fast-moving thing a
war is a fast-moving thing
if the u.s and china ended up having a
war something i talk about towards the
end of the book
which is history leads us to think it's
quite likely
that would be a disaster particularly if
it
escalated into nuclear war um that would
be far
larger and and more fast-acting
than the scenarios of uh
you know the ipcc i mean i almost think
that climate change
i don't think it's necessarily zooey
generous but it doesn't fit into
the same kind of worries it's a big
worry i think it's it's a huge worry but
like you said it's gradual right we can
sort of plot it we're in the middle of
it it's going to take decades
uh to progress to wherever it goes
whether we
do something about it or not whereas
things like the pandemic the financial
crisis
you brought up asteroids before solar
flares are my favorite example of
something we just don't think about at
all that could
wreak havoc on our entire world in all
those examples
the to me the big problem is
you know there's a probability that it
will happen but it's small
and therefore it might not happen for
other hundred years or a thousand years
and we human beings
just aren't built to plan for those
things i mean
we could fix you know firm up the
electrical grid to save it from solar
flares
with a relatively tiny amount of money
but who's gonna do that for a one in a
thousand per year chance
of such a disaster that's right and and
the point of the book is not that we
should be taking out insurance policies
against all of these eventualities
that would be i think a council of of
the impossible
my feeling is more that we need to
keep our breadth of vision in
recognizing that
ultimately we don't get
the disaster we plan for we almost never
do
and if we spend too much time which i
think we risk doing
thinking about one particular set of
scenarios
which are the kind of the bad scenarios
in the ipcc
uh then i think we'll be blindsided by
something
else ultimately going back to the
earlier points
the generally paranoid society
has some kind of contingency for
the temporary but perhaps
prolonged failure of the electricity
grid
and that could happen not just because
of solar flares it could happen because
of a successful chinese russian cyber
attack conceivably
i worry that if if we convince ourselves
that
the key thing for us to do
between now and the next 20 years is
radically to reduce carbon dioxide
emissions if we do that we'll be fine
then we are i think engaging in a kind
of magical thinking
so i'm i'm really trying and i know i'm
in good company because people like nick
bostrom have
been doing this for some time to point
out that
uh if if there's one thing history tells
you it's that you
don't get the disaster you prepare for
and the more you think about one
disaster and fixate on one
apocalypse the less ready you'll be for
something completely different and i
think we were
really unready imaginatively unready for
a pandemic
despite numerous warnings on the subject
we had allowed ourselves
to drift into a state of mind and that
included people in the public health
bureaucracies that was actually
disastrously
unready for something that was far from
a black swan i mean it wasn't a black
swan we knew it was coming yeah
martin reece had a bet with steve pinker
about it
i i'm just constantly struck by the fact
that
when it strikes it suddenly becomes a
black swan
for years it's been a grey rhino that
people have talked about and written
about and predicted about and given ted
talks about but when it actually happens
we're all stunned shocked shocked that
there could be such a thing as a
an infectious respiratory disease so
it's a little worrying to me that we
might respond in exactly the same way to
a full-scale war because we've been
accustomed to small wars
what we can largely ignore but grumble
about
the thing about it is that most human
beings
have a theory of history based on their
own experience
they really don't tend to internalize
the experience
of all the dead people and
and that's a lot more people's will than
all the living people
so what one has to do i think and this
was the goal of the book doom was to
remind
people of the experience of the dead
and all the different ways that they got
dead
and there is a hint of almost kind of a
strategy in there but i want to
interrogate
the extent which we do this in the sense
that you point out that the more
paranoid countries
the countries that sort of live in fear
paranoid is the wrong word because it's
justified right
countries that worry about existential
threats
of a completely different form were
seemingly much better at responding to
this new kind of threat that they hadn't
necessarily
planned for so that seems to suggest
okay
we should worry a little bit more about
various kinds of existential threats to
give ourselves the
nimble strategic ability to respond when
they happen
there must be a downside of that as well
right i mean do we worry about
uh clamping down on civil liberties and
individual choice a bit too quickly
or being a bit too paranoid when new
disasters are
on the horizon well the conclusion of
the book is that our biggest danger
might in fact be
a totalitarianism that we construct out
of risk aversion
after all it's very easy to say and i've
heard it said look how well the chinese
handled this and they were able to
handle it so
well because they have unprecedented
levels of surveillance and and social
control
this is the totally wrong conclusion to
draw from the events of the last 12 or
14 months the conclusion of draw is that
precisely china's totalitarian system
made this disaster happen
this was super chernobyl and it came
about because
the system just can't tell the truth in
the early stages of a disaster
so we have to draw lessons from the
right
china by which i mean taiwan uh the
taiwanese
have understood i think partly with
the leadership of audrey tang their
their technology minister that
you must use technology in ways that
empower
citizens not that empower the state and
when i was there i
by chance was there in january 2020
before the pandemic really
uh became a recognized phenomenon but
they were already worrying about it
they'd already heard enough to be
worried what struck me was how much
thought they'd put into using
smartphones in ways that
that did not give power to big brother
but would make possible
and it turned out to be very possible a
system of contact tracing and
and digital quarantining so they had
really addressed this
and i think the reason that they've been
so good at this
is that they have to be paranoid they
are right next door
to the people's republic of china which
essentially claims to control
and own them uh
israel has the same i think feature of
of institutionalized or situational
uh insecurity apart from a really nasty
period last summer when they lost
control of the pandemic israel performed
well at the beginning and it's
absolutely hit the ball out of the park
with vaccination
south korea is in the same category good
reasons to be paranoid when your
neighbor is
kim jong-un so i think that's what's
interesting to me that these societies
have
managed to combine uh
a general level of uh wariness let's say
without sacrificing individual liberties
and
crucially and this this is where i
thought you might be going
without ceasing to be innovative because
in the end
we got to innovate our way out of all of
these different
threats and i i see it as being far from
an accident that the cutting edge
semiconductor manufacturer in the world
today is tsmc
right there in the heart of of taiwan
that israel has become such an
innovative society despite
the fact that it can't really scale
within its own
own borders and south korea is also a
technological
leader so i think you can definitely
have vigilance
uh without uh an authoritarian
or totalitarian faith actually the price
of liberty
is eternal vigilance a phrase i was
brought up
to revere my grandfather loved to quote
it at me and it's true
it's true that's that's the way to think
about this i think we face a major risk
from totalitarianism i think we
we face it not only from china and and
other
uh totalitarian states that are aligned
with it we face it from within because
our increasing preoccupation with
mitigating all risks including the risks
to our children
this preoccupation is leading i think
to a dangerous safety first mentality
which will encourage us has already
encouraged us to
to give up um a dangerous amount of
of our our individual freedom uh
to accept a dangerous amount of of
surveillance
so yeah i think i think there's a good
way of thinking about this
the first the first thing to to stress
is that
totalitarian regimes caused the biggest
disasters in history
not just the holocaust but the holodomar
in in ukraine
the terrible disasters that mao
inflicted in china particularly the
great leap forward
so at all costs if we want to avoid
disaster we should want to avoid
totalitarianism
no i mean i think that's a very good
point it brings us back to the sort of
complex systems
network perspective where
uh i mean is there it's hard to avoid
making grandiose pronouncements here so
yeah let's do it and we can put the
caveats in later but the more resilient
systems are
a bit more decentralized right i mean
you mentioned innovation also
the ability to experiment try different
things i can absolutely imagine
that being more like a network rather
than a hierarchy
lets societies respond better
to unanticipated disasters of various
sorts
um i mean maybe you want to say
something about that but then maybe if i
think about the
the flip side of that some disasters are
going to require
cooperation right i mean climate change
maybe is that example i mean
or or peacekeeping or you know nuclear
weapons treaties or something like that
is there is there a trade-off there
between resiliency from distribution
versus
safety from hierarchy i think there's a
clearly a trade-off i think we know from
successful experiments in international
cooperation
the eradication of smallpox
the avoidance of a perpetual and endless
nuclear arms race the
the limitation of the use of chemical
weapons we know how to do this
and we know that interstate agreements
can
prevent we prevented nuclear
proliferation to a far greater extent
than was predictable
back in in the late 1960s when the
non-proliferation treaty was drawn up so
i think
we actually have a pretty good track
record we got better
in fact that kind of international
agreement it took
a long time for there to be good
international agreements on on public
health
the first sanitary conferences of the
late 19th century were pretty
inconclusive
but by the mid-20th century we'd come up
with a world health organization which
was doing a pretty good job until
well let's maybe not get into that but
until uh
i think china became too powerful over
its uh over its organization
and uh and leadership so i think this
isn't this isn't one of the big
headaches
i think decentralization is crucial
for a great many problems but not
all and a federal system with
vibrant local governments ought to be
able to act with
national uh unity in the face of a dire
emergency and
the biggest emergencies have tended to
be wars through through history and
we've
uh we've generally been able to overcome
uh the the coordination problems of
decentralized
and democratic states in time of war i
felt i found it odd that
people struggled so hard to think about
a murder an emergency last year
that in an emergency you temporarily
have to give up
certain freedoms that didn't really
puzzle our grandparents
uh and great-grandparents in time of war
but we've definitely lost that
uh that notion that you have a temporary
suspension of
freedom in time of of emergency
for the global challenges i think one
has to recognize
that there's a fundamental mismatch
between what states will commit to
in things like the paris accord
and how their commitments will be
enforced
ultimately the problem that we face at
the moment
when we come back to the problem of
climate change which i like you take
very seriously there's no question that
we're
we're heading to a more unstable planet
if we carry on on our present trajectory
and it's going to involve
mass migration and potentially
starvation in those parts of the world
that become
less easy to to live in but what have we
got we've got a situation in which the
chinese say one thing and do another
more than or roughly half of all the
increase
in co2 emissions since greta tunberg was
born
are from china and they haven't stopped
building
coal burning power stations on the
contrary they ramped it up in the last
year
and nobody has a good answer to the
question how do you enforce
these commitments nobody has a good
answer to that at all
and until we have a good answer to that
then i think there's a risk of virtue
signaling
where europeans and americans say well
we're going to do
all these wonderful things to be carbon
neutral it won't make the blindest bit
of difference if the chinese carry on on
their present path
it really won't we'll we'll essentially
just uh
impair our economic growth potentially
or maybe we'll get it right and avoid
that but we won't actually solve the
problem if the chinese carry on and the
indians do and
there are some middle eastern countries
that are uh increasing their co2
emissions rather shockingly so i
i don't know what the answer to that is
but i do think that it ultimately
becomes part of cold war ii i think
we're in a cold war now with china we
don't really want to face it but we are
and the chinese know it
and at the heart of that cold war is
going to be
finding ways of enforcing uh
commitments that the chinese have have
made and
i i think it'll take a while but at one
point maybe it'll dawn on
on joe biden tony blinken and jake
sullivan but but it didn't dawn on their
predecessors
they'll realize that the climate issue
is actually a geopolitical issue
it's a fundamental problem that we
should not be surprised by remember the
soviet union was in its way an
absolutely disastrous producer
didn't not not on the chinese scale but
it was still a
characteristic feature of the
totalitarian state that it doesn't
care at all about the externalities it
just doesn't care because there's no
accountability there's no property
rights no rule of law
of course the communist parties will
always do
pollution it's just that we've never
seen it done on this on this massive
scale before
well i mean let's bring that back to the
discussion about networks and
revolutions and so forth um
you know i china is some a place i have
very mixed feelings about because you
know i look back
at the the cultural and history of it
and
i wanted to be one of the polls leading
the world
in some sense but then of course it's an
auto autocratic dictatorship with like
you said
very very uh narrow self-interests is
there any hope for thinking that in the
modern networked world
uh a large large-scale autocracy like
that
is less stable than it might have been i
mean i know that china tries very hard
to keep out
information flows but can they do that
is there some hope for
the people of china to shrug off the
autocracy that is in charge of them
i try to be optimistic about about this
i think that ultimately
the idea that you can take the mid 20th
century totalitarian model of the one
party state and the strong
charismatic leader and replay it
in the 2010s and 2020s is mad
the idea ultimately that that you can
build a surveillance state
on the internet using uh
a combination of human and ai censorship
that you could make that work i can't
in my heart of hearts believe it
but when you go to china and watch it in
action
you realize that they have come further
than
orwell imagined in 1984 because the
telescreen was on your wall
not in your pocket and
and there was nothing remotely
resembling facial recognition of the
sort that the
chinese police can now use in in urban
china so
you'd have to say at this point that
totalitarianism 2.0
is is doing better than anybody for saw
in the 1990s when clinton famously said
that you can't nail
jello to a wall they've poured a nail
geller to a wall
i think the key problem is that as the
growth rate slows
for demographic reasons and because of
the excessive debt burden
the regime will more and more be
inclined to rely on nationalism
to maintain its legitimacy that pattern
is already
well established since she took over
and it's producing a kind of tone in
their
diplomacy sometimes referred to as wolf
warrior diplomacy that is
alarming to me because it's it's so
reminiscent of
of shrill belligerent regimes of the
past
so i think that the real key question is
at what point does this dynamic
lead to actual war as opposed to wars of
words
and that will be where the fate of the
regime is decided
because if it loses it's over
that's kind of how i'm beginning to
realize this will play out
i don't think that
you can combine one belt one road claims
to taiwan
crushing of democracy in hong kong
increasing assertiveness in the south
china sea
i don't think you can combine those
things with a
propaganda that is increasingly
nationalistic and not at some point get
into a conflict
unless the u.s just rolls over and says
okay carry on become the primacy the
become the hegemon in the in the pacific
region
so i'm i'm kind of with graham allison
that the probability of conflict is
is quite high under these circumstances
and probably that's how this regime
ultimately comes apart just as
totalitarian regimes in the past did
because
they they actually can start a war
but they can't win a war because i think
what's
clear from the 20th century is that
when the united states
or for that matter uh the british empire
when they were put to the test they
actually came through
and they came through because and i
remember writing about this in the war
of the world
when you took american capitalism and
said go win a conventional war and if
you can't win it
come up with atomic weapons that worked
and the soviet union found it could not
compete in the cold war any more than
the
imperial japanese and and nazi german
forces had been able to win
world war ii so i think the chinese
ultimately if they end up on collision
course will
will not win but it's a messy prospect
and i hope we i hope we can find a way
of avoiding this
i'd far rather see i'd far rather see
a gradual transformation of chinese
politics
away from the one-party state we all
hope that what would happen
20 years ago that was the game plan
globalization would bring them into the
fold
but it's it's not happened on the
contrary they've they've turned the
clock back
ideologically the universities are no
longer places one can speak freely and
the party's power has
has tightened in a way that is really
quite
quite frightening so it's hard to see
the optimistic scenario playing out the
probability of that optimistic
transition has gone way down
in the last 20 years particularly since
she took over well it goes back to where
we started with the fact that history is
neither uniformly progressive nor
cyclic there's a bunch of different
factors that that come together
in unique ways every time so it's hard
to predict on the basis of past
performance what's going to happen next
so
the sample size of cold wars is at what
point one or two
and that makes it pretty hard to
generalize
oh we could do it we can generalize i'm
sure we could do it somehow
uh but actually let's make that the last
question you know you're
you're a historian by uh by label
uh growing up with physicists does not
stop you from doing this but
you're writing about extremely
contemporary
ideas right i mean i don't know when you
had the idea to write a book
on catastrophes in the middle of a
pandemic but uh it's certainly something
where every week
things were changing right i mean so let
me just give you the last question to
let you expound on the idea of the role
of the historian
comment commenting on contemporary
events whatever
whatever those events might be i mean is
it possible to
learn from the successes and failures of
past historians do historians have
something
extra to offer when we think about
current events
i think i became a historian because i
wanted to
think about contemporary problems and
plausible futures
i didn't want to study the past just
because it was kind of
interesting for its own sake though that
was what we were told to do at oxford
i remember being told told explicitly
by the regis professor michael howard
that we couldn't learn lessons from
history that was the only lesson of
history
and i've always resisted that council of
despair
i think what historians have to
offer is different from the models that
social scientists or epidemiologists
have to offer
we work in a way that can seem
rather fuzzier with analogies
and i think because if we're doing our
job well as r.g collingwood put it the
great oxford philosopher of history we
we get a sense of
that the tigers in the grass
we get a pattern recognition skill over
time unlike mathematicians historians
should get better at being historians
the older they get
because they should get better at the
pattern recognition
and what we're really there for is to
say
i'll give you one example when you think
about a pandemic
don't think of one curve that you have
to flatten there will be multiple waves
that's what to expect i remember saying
that back in
in march when another neil ferguson was
getting a good deal more airtime than me
on the isle ferguson at imperial college
i thought
he was making a mistake in thinking that
we faced 1918-19 i.e
a pandemic as bad as that one i never uh
could see that even on the limited data
we then had from china
it just didn't look like being that
deadly a virus
but you asked a good question when did i
think of doing this because it's sort of
mad isn't it to write a history of
disaster
before the disaster in in progress is
over yeah it's still going on
i actually wanted to do this before uh
before covert 19 was even heard of i i
had a lunch with my editor in
in new york and i said okay i i'm really
i really want to write about
the the various disastrous scenarios
that we've
we've envisioned in science fiction as
well as in
uh religious eschatology and i i think
it's
it's it's a great subject to write a
kind of history of our relationship with
with the end of the world or with
wonster
and he was like
[Laughter]
no one wants to hear about that first
most often science fiction for much of
the previous
year i'd had this sudden epiphany that
history was great for pattern
recognition
about certain classic phenomena
like war but it was bad at helping you
anticipate technological change
and so i i decided to resume reading
science fiction which i'd stopped doing
at the age of about 17
to try to give myself a better sense of
uh of potential technological
dislocations
became entirely obsessed with uh lucy
shin's three body problem
and uh and and got very excited about
how we could kind of combine historical
framework with science fiction
and then covert 19 came along and there
there i'd won the argument at that point
because a classically science fiction
scenario one that many different science
fictions have been written about a
pandemic was
there and um and i i won my argument and
got to write the book
but yeah a lot of the book is not about
covert 19 because i i couldn't possibly
write the history of something that
wasn't over it's just the last
three chapters that touch on the the
unfolding events
uh the book goes all the way back to the
the
prehistoric disasters the great volcanic
eruptions that nobody was there to write
about
not to mention the asteroids that
conveniently stopped hitting the earth
during our time
and and i hope that it's got some
utility
i've used the phrase applied history a
lot
i i think that we made a mistake in the
history of our
our discipline we didn't create a kind
of department of applied history
we we should have done so that people
like me could go off
and and try to do uh a kind of history
that would be designed to deal with
contemporary problems
i'm hoping to be able to build that
though it's a huge challenge
i think we failed to create departments
of economic history when we could have
done
and uh and and the current departments
of history are not doing this work at
all
they've basically moved into a domain of
cultural history and
identity politics they're disengaged
from contemporary problems mostly and
as far as i can see they're mostly
concerned about com
condemning the past for its racism and
sexism and general
lack of workness and that just bores me
that's to me that's utterly
uninteresting going back in the past and
condemning slavery i i find that a
sterile use of of of time
i'm much more interested in in thinking
about how we can learn from past
experience to
contend with future problems
and so applied history is really what
what doom is supposed to illustrate
and i i hope that policymakers can read
it and think
aha yeah what went wrong in 2020
in the domain of public health could go
wrong in a lot of other domains
and that's why we need to think more
historically and less legalistically
about
the problems and challenges we're likely
to face i should also give you a chance
to mention you did edit a whole
collection on virtual history where
people
thought about counterfactuals and maybe
that's something that historians could
think about more
well i think it's odd that most
historians
disapprove of counterfactual history in
fact one
in particular richard evans wrote a
whole book condemning the
the exercise but i actually think if you
take a
few seconds to reflect on the philosophy
of history that you can't make any
meaningful causal statement where
without an implicit counter factual
for example covet 19 would have been
much less disastrous if
hillary clinton had been president i
think one has to make those statements
explicit and then interrogate them
because i don't think it's by any means
obvious that a democratic administration
would have handled covet 19
significantly better how did they do
with the opioid
epidemic which was slower moving not
global
and it was worse every year of the obama
presidency in terms of
the numbers who died so i think
to me counterfactual questions are
indispensable
and they need to be asked about the
recent past
the more you think counterfactually and
this is the real
key i think about the past the more you
recognize
that the future is it's not determined
it's uncertain
you and i stand before multiple
plausible futures
and all we can really do at this point
is attach some
vague probabilities to them but the more
you try and do that systematically
the more you realize how hard it is i
spend a lot of my time
trying to do that if i'm getting 66
right i'm doing really really well just
you know beating the coin tosses is good
because this is so difficult to do i
mean even if you're just
narrowly trying to predict where
interest rates will be a month from now
it's really hard
so doing counterfactual history is a way
of reminding yourself that
what happened was not bound to happen
it's just the scenarios the sequence of
events that we got
but ex-ante did not have necessarily
even the highest probability sometimes
it's the low probability scenarios that
happen
so i think council factual thinking is
extremely healthy
and it should be it should be kind of
much more central to how we educate
people
not only to think about big questions
like the future of the united states but
also about how to think about their own
lives
yeah i i'm on your side here i think
that what human beings are good at and
should try to become better at is
imagining all the futures
assigning probabilities to them vague or
otherwise and then taking them seriously
rather than
waiting for them to happen and go oh yes
i could i could have predicted that
so brielle ferguson thanks very much for
being on the mindscape podcast
thank you so much sean great questions
[Music]
you